Hello 大家好 我是[来源标识已去除]欢迎大家来到[来源标识已去除]出品的拼多多商家成长训练营的第三节课程
标签人群定义标签人群定义其实这个里面分成了三个板块
第一个到底什么是标签因为上节课程才跟大家去讲到了权重人群流量等等这些东西
那么整个的标签的定义呢我给大家去总结了两句话
第一个标签是告诉系统我的产品能卖给谁销售给谁
系统根据产品的标签去精准匹配用户的推荐和搜索
也就是我们在权中里面提到了搜索属性啊
推荐属性啊 用活动去进行加权
那么我给大家去个人去进行总结一下呢
就是整个标签的定义就是从购买的所有的行为的路径称为标签
也就是标签是所有在用户决策层里面最小的一个东西
有了这些标签以后 市场知道推荐给谁 谁去进行搜索的时候 我的产品能优先去进行展现
那么整个的标签你可以理解为成交的一个所有路径 从曝光点击咨询收藏购买复购以及推荐
所以有成交的产品他才会有标签 有成交的路径他才会有标签 那么
成交最小的单位其实是整个SQ里面最小的一个档
这个是精准人群的行为标签 所以很多人以为说标签就是我的产品必须购买之后才会有标签
其实不是 别人从看到你的那一刻开始他就有了标签
因为在整个标签里面他会做分类 一个是系统标签 一个是内容标签
就是消费者在搜索你的产品的时候 在Apple里面去进行搜索你产品的时候
或者说是在你的整个手印里面去进行搜索你产品的时候
他就已经给我的这款产品打上了标签 因为系统标签是要给平台去看
那么内容标签是给用户去进行看 那么给平台看的时候呢
你就会牵扯那个东西 在发布链接的时候
有一个东西叫标准化链接的制作 后面的课程我给大家去进行讲到
从 主图 标题 详情 SQO SQO文字 SQO图片
以及店铺的设置在属性里面去进行选择 举个很简单的例子
比如说我需要卖这件蓝式的毛衣 我优先选择的肯定是蓝装这个类目
这个里面就会有一个系统的标签 第二个 我发布在蓝装类目里面的毛衣
诶 我的标签就更精准了 再往下面去进行发布 我的这款产品 我在主图上面去写 我在我的标题上面去写 我在我的SQ里面 在你们的详情里面去进行写
核心消费人群适用于25岁到35岁左右的职业化蓝性 诶 这个其实就是这样的标签
其实你可以理解为标签其实是人群背后的最小的一个计量单位 好 再往下面去进行走
内容标签是什么 内容标签其实是给用户去进行看的 也就是我刚刚就讲到的一个东西
就是我的标题里面可以去进行写啊 我的卖点是什么不起球 不掉毛
哎 我的尺码是什么样的一个东西 我包邮哎 我的工厂直销啊 我的产品比较便宜啊
啊 价格等等等等等等这些东西 所以是两个核心的一个标签定义 那么
讲了流量 讲了权重 现在到了标签 那我们这些标签其实是做给谁看的 核心记住啊 是做给
系统看的 系统根据你的产品 近期内所获取到的所有的一个行为的路径
在他的这个大的流量池里面 给你去进行筛选 匹配更多和你产品适用的一个人群
所以呢 举个例子给大家去听一下 我是卖这款毛衣的 我的毛衣是羊绒 某某 尺码 黑色 蓝色 白色等等等等等等这些东西
它适用于买的人是什么呢 25岁到30岁左右的年金小伙子会买 买完我之后呢 我的产品就会给系统打上一个标签 那么系统再去进行匹配的时候呢 就会有这样一个东西 那么讲了这些底层的逻辑完之后 我们获取权重 我们知道 那我们获取标签的方式又分为哪几种呢 其实是分成了以下几种
第一个 价格，你可以让价格很低 让用户通过价格给你的产品打上标签 第二个 付费 第三个 活动 那么如果说你现在在拼多多里面去打价格战
我还会有两个东西 第一个 卷供应链 第二个 偷供减尿 因为便宜没好货 好货永远不便宜
再加上现在的拼多多对品质 评分的要求非常非常的高 所以获取标签的方式和获取权重的方式呢 有那么一丢丢的差距
因为标签是最小的一个东西 最终要落地的
你要想用户百分之百看到你的产品 曝光 点击 咨询 购买
你只能通过这三个方式 第一个 价格 便宜 我一定会购买
第二个 付费 你的合理定价 付费盈利 上去让它产生标签
第三个 活动 我去做品牌的黑标 我去授权一个黑标
我做品牌的货 比如说联合逆华里面出的东西 比如说白草味里面出的东西
比如说三只松鼠里面出的东西 这些产品其实都可以去上百亿
那么比如说我没有这些品牌的资源 我是通过价格 我是通过房比价
我是上活动 秒杀万人团等等等等
所以获取标签的方式尤且只有这三种
至于你们很多人会说标题 主图 详情 SKU等等这些东西
这个东西属于什么 属于标签的分类
我需要在类目里面去把它做好 属性里面去把它做好
所以做店铺它是有流程的 做报款也是有流程的
你必须清晰的去知道整个平台给我们这些商家能提供哪些东西
他给我们的东西无外乎就这三个东西
价格这个东西是看得见猫不着的
付费是你所应当的
活动也能看得见
那么它的流程是什么
从曝光点击咨询收藏
总结下来呢
就是你获取点击的速度怎么样
那么权重里面讲到了量大于率
那么在标签里面呢
讲的其实是关于点击的速度
点击速度往上面就进行推挡的情况下
我有了足够的曝光量
那么我的点击率如果变高
我的点击速度一定会很大
我的点击量一定会很高
第二个标签是需要去做加法的
这个给大家去举个例子你们可能就明白了
就是我的产品上完价之后
我为什么会把一个卖99块钱的毛衣定价定成199
我用限时限量购打折
我用优惠券去打折
最终成为99元钱
其实是在给我的整个产品再去做加法
同时第三个呢就是资源规的叠加
也就是在当下的整个拼多多里面
所获取曝光点击收藏购买
最终的这个行为成为标签
标签越精准
你的产品的点击转化能力越高
且权重越高
所以权重越等于订单
它只是一个框架
那么在它这个细致的里面呢
要去提到从你产品获取曝光
那么我再深入的一区跟大家去进行聊一下
你的产品刚刚去进行上架
你要想让你的曝光量变得很大很大的情况下
你能怎么去进行解决呢
你要想让你的点击变成
很大很大的情况下
你怎么去进行解决呢
有的产品有咨询
有的产品没有咨询
那么我们最后写一个购买
我们怎么去进行哪些路径去进行解决呢
曝光或许曝光的两个路径到底是什么呢
三个路径到底是什么呢
第一个价格低
但是低在拼多多里面多低算低
所以我们会去做进价截牛
所以玩法应认而生
第二个我去做付费
所以呢我会有强付费
第三个我去做活动
我可能有百亿
就是你获取曝光的手段
你尤其可能只有这三个
你不可能逃出这三个以外
所以拼多多里面所有的玩法
其实都在前面平台的认知的几节课程里面
所以呢我在跟你们去讲这一套课程的时候
前面的课程为什么让你们一直听
一直听
因为所有的拼多多商家和拼多多运营以及工厂的负责人 公司的大老板 品牌方
你都应该去听听[来源标识已去除]的三节课程就是关于平台的这个认知
因为这个所有的东西都是从这里面去进行延伸出去的
我们做运营外国是在去提曝光
我想把这个东西提高我用什么样的方式和手段
那么点击过去的方式是什么啊
图片足够的可以骗人
就是马匾图
但是拼多多现在不允许你有太多的马匾图
再往下面去走直接一点啊
大字
那再往下面去购买
那不就是又回到了一个死循环价格
或者是你找到一个合适的人群
所以
标签的最终的定义
我给大家去进行个人总结一下
就是把所有东西都合起来的情况下
我们只要记住一个东西
标签的最终的定义是从消费者
消费者看到你这个产品开始算起
它其实就已经有了标签
就是很多人说
我在首页浏览的时候
我看到了这个青桃老火腿
我看到了这个被子
我看到了这个鱿鱼
我看到了这个纸巾
算不算标签
算
但是标签比较弱而已
所以我才会跟大家去讲
标签最终的路径是
成交和推荐标签是最大最大的
那么获取标签的方式呢
价格 付费 活动
标签的行为路径呢
曝光 点击 咨询 收藏 购买 推荐 复购
所以获取标签的方式
其实是在给我们所有的商家上了一个比较生动的一个东西
你买一个东西立刻马上下手
是先让他看见
那么回到我们底层逻辑里面来
后期怎么去进行运用呢
很多人说我上架产品没有访客
没有牛量
那么你解决访客和牛量最终的路径
当下的拼多多不就是付费出价吗
不就是付费出价高吗
但是你又会面临一个很核心的问题
付费出价高
我会面临的问题是亏损
但是我们直通之后才还有个东西叫限额
所以限额递增的由来是从底层逻辑里面去进行出发的
这个呢就是当下的整个拼多多里面
我想跟大家去传输这个东西叫标圈的人群定义
所以一切的玩法的根本都在底层逻辑里面
那么这些课程给大家去讲到这里
我是[来源标识已去除]
祝大家天天报单